استهدف قصف وسط مدينه دنياسك التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الروسيه لها في الشرق
اوكرانيا واستهدف القذف سوقا تجاريا
وكنيسه اضافه الى مستودعات تجاريه قريبه
من محطه للكهرباء في المدينه مراسلاتنا
سلام خضر والتفاصيل
اذا نحن الان في وسط مدينه دنيتك هذا
المكان السوق التجاري المفتوح الذي يبدو
خلفي وتندلع منه السنه اللهب والدخان
استهدف قبل قليل بعده صواريخ اوكرانيه فرق
الاطفاء تحاول السيطر على الحريق وتحاول
فرق الاسعاف ايضا الدخول
لانقاذ المحاصرين حتى الان لا نعرف ان كان
هناك اعداد كبيره من المواطنين داخل هذا
السوق ولكن فرق الاطفاء تعمل حاليا على
السيطره على النيران هذا احد الشوارع
الاساسيه
السلطات المحليه هنا تقول ان المدينه ومنذ
نحو اسبوع تتعرض لما تصفه السلطات هنا
بانه الاستهداف الاعنف والاكثر كثافه منذ
بدء الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا او ما
تسميها موسكو العمليه العسكريه الخاصه الى
جانب السوق هنا احدى الكاتدرائيات سقط
عليها ايضا صاروخ من ضمن مجموعه صواريخ
التي اطلقت قبل قليل على دنياسك حتى الان
لا نعرف ان كان احد قد اصيب داخل هذه
الكنيسه سلام خضر الجزيره من وسط مدينه
دمياط